And everybody, it's Dr. Conner, so this is episode eight of my
journey through cancer, just sharing with you what I think has been helping me a lot in
and my cancer journey.
So here's some more helpful hints of things that I have been going through.
This is going to be on what I'm taking with enzymes, if you've looked at any other videos,
in mind, I'm a big fan of enzyme therapy. It was actually really put on the map by this guy,
Dr. William Kelly, back in the 50s and 60s and 70s. He helped people with cancer using high
enzyme therapy. Dr. Nicholas Gonzalez, who just passed away a few years ago of a heart attack,
was a medical doctor in New York who devoted his whole practice to helping
cancer patients. He was actually a strong acquaintance of mine. I had met him at a seminar
years and years ago. He was just a fantastic, godly guy. He just really was just a great guy,
had utmost respect for him. He was a huge fan of Dr. Kelly. Dr. Kelly passed away. I don't know
where he passed away, but Nick Gonzalez, new Dr. Kelly, and he wrote a book, One Man Alone.
This book is on Dr. Kelly's work. Enzyme therapy was put on the map
with the understated. Actually, Dr. Kelly studied Dr. Bard's work from the early 1900s with
enzyme therapy. That's where he got the idea. The idea is that because a cancer is
rapidly replicating, it's producing a lot of waste. That waste is one reason why the immune system
isn't able to penetrate that mass and able to kill the cancer. That's one of the reasons why it
has a difficult time. Using high dose enzymes, paediatric enzymes is what Dr. Kelly used and Dr.
Gonzalez used as well. Using high dose paediatric enzymes, you could help digest that waste. You're
basically helping the live clear that away so that your immune system can help attack the cancer.
Doing enzymes alone is not the therapy. It's using enzymes to help break down that excess
waste around a growing cancer so that your immune system, then you have to use some immune stimulants
and such, can get at the cancer and help break it down. Using enzymes would be a good adjunct if you
were doing like a immunotherapy, like ketruda, because ketruda works on the cancer cell itself
to basically turn off its ability to turn off T cells. That's how ketruda and immunotherapy works.
A very promising new therapy in cancer therapy. But ketruda doesn't work if it can't get to the
cancer cell. Same thing with chemotherapy, though, it's not targeted. Chemotherapy works by being
able to get to the cancer cell itself. So, enzyme therapy can be an adjunct to alternative and to
standard therapies in cancer. So, it's something that everybody should at least consider doing some
enzymes of some sort. Now, we use the very enzymes that Dr. Kelly used and Dr. Gonzalez used,
the pancreatic enzymes. We still use those and we use those for years and tell a company called
US enzymes came out with an enzyme that I think is far better than that. And I'm going to show you the
ones that I personally use and that we use on a lot of patients. Now, of course, we test people with
good etiology and we use whichever ones are going to work best for them, at least what we believe.
But these are the ones that I'm using. And again, caveat to all these episodes is just because it's
working for me, or it's working for me right now. It doesn't mean it's going to continue to work for me
and you have to cut it constantly tweak things when you're dealing with cancer. And just because it may be
working for me does not mean it's going to work for you. So, just remember that. But here's, I use
several products from this company's line. And one of the reasons why I like US enzymes, I mean, I do not
hold any of the company or anything like that. But one of the reasons why I like it is I know the
orders of the company and they are the most crazy needle people as far as perfection and cleanliness
and purity of their products. So many supplement companies out there, they're just selling
supplements. They don't care if what's on the label is really in the pill. Quite honestly, it's really
become a crooked business. Now, US enzymes is one of the companies that I try, I think I trust them more
than I trust any other company on the market. Maybe these guys in standard process would be the two
most highly respectable companies that I've seen as far as having a greater line of products.
So these are the ones that I use. This digestimes, this HClzyme. Now, I only use this HClzyme
what I'm eating a meal. This helps really to digest foods. I think I have a slide on this, yes.
So the digestimes is really, this would be the equivalent of Dr. Kelly's enzyme. Actually, I think it's
far better. The amount of enzymes that are in here are far more than what are in Dr. Kelly's original
enzymes. So I think this is just a phenomenal product. Now, the purpose of taking enzymes to
cancer is that you're not taking them with your meal. So if you're taking enzymes, a lot of people
take digestive enzymes with their meals. You're taking digestive enzymes with your meals to help digest
the food that you just ate. That would be this product. So I take HClzyme when I eat a meal.
That helps me break down. The food takes a lot of stress off my gut since I have a testicist to my
colon. Then I don't want that stress on my colon. So I take this when I eat a meal. You take
digestive enzymes for cancer between meals on a more empty stomach. So I take these on an empty
stomach. So these are on an empty stomach to help break down the waste around the cancer as I was
explaining. These I take with a meal. And quite honestly, I don't take these with every meal. I take
maybe once a day on my larger meal. Some days I don't take them at all. So these ones I take on an
empty stomach. And I take these two to three times a day. So I take these two to three times a day.
I take these once a day, maybe five days a week. And then the other thing I take are the other
same line. It's got enzymes in it, but it's really not taking for the purpose of an enzyme. This
product is called chlorozyme. It has blue-green algae, spirulina, and chlorella. I really take this
to help by liver. So it's got some probiotic in it. Also, it's got to astrozyme. So it's got to
enzymes in it to help with the proper utilization of this and the gut so I can absorb it. But this
is really mainly for the liver and for helping get out heavy metals. And you know that I have a
mercury issue. So that's why I'm taking that. Then I also take this clenzyme. This also has an
enzyme. That's why the enzyme at the end of it. These are the enzymes that are in it, but I begin to
not take this for the purpose of the enzymes per se. I'm taking this for by liver. This has got milk,
this old turkey, rhubarb, alfalfa, algae, dandelion root, great herb for your liver, and for digestion,
Zeta and wheat grass. So this is just a great detox as what this is. So I take this as well as the
digestime and the chlorozyme, and I take these, those three three times a day. Sometimes only twice a
day, but two to three times a day for sure. And then the HCls, I again, I only take that with a meal.
But these ones I take between meals on an empty stomach, and then every day I take probiotic. And I
go between this US enzymes product probiotic because it's a great probiotic and a different brand
probiotic than it didn't pull a picture of it up here. It's from another company and I switch back
and forth. And I'm a big fan of switching back and forth on your probiotics from different companies
because you're going to get different strains. So the more variety of strains that you can get,
I think, you're better. It's better off for you. Now this gives you, I love this product. It's probably
a favorite probiotic that we have right now because of the different strains that it gives you to give
you the greatest variety of strains that any other one we have. So this is a great probiotic. But these
are the things I've been taking. And again, I think they're working quite well for me.
So again, this is just a piece of my protocol and I'll continue to share it more. So hopefully this helps.
And you guys have a great day.